okay
okay hi everyone welcome to another
episode of uh
history of science and technology q a
and i see i have a whole bunch of
questions here
all right here's a here's a tricky one
this is from slayer
in my opinion uh who is the most snubbed
scientist or inventor uh slayer says his
would be or hers would be um rosalind
franklin
okay so this is a complicated question
what
you know
you know what causes scientists
inventors to be snubbed in some way when
people invent things and everybody
ignores what they invented what's going
on
i think there are a couple of things to
say
there are
cases in which sort of once you
understand something you can go back and
say oh people almost got that a long
time ago or people saw that phenomenon
and
well they didn't really understand what
it was but they saw the phenomenon
and so maybe it was snubbing them to not
pay attention to the fact that they saw
the phenomenon you know i've just
recently been uh that hopefully it'll
get posted tomorrow uh been working on
kind of a
i think rather important thing that's
come out of our physics project that's
sort of a a new paradigm for thinking
about modeling in theoretical science
that i'm calling the multi-computational
paradigm
and one thing that's interesting about
it is i was trying to write the history
of the multi-computational paradigm i
think i now understand what it is with
some clarity
and now you can go back and look at the
history and you can see traces of it
over the last hundred years
and you can see many different traces in
many different places
but
they are
they don't quite nail it they don't
quite
kind of
get the point of it
they get other points which have been
relevant for lots of other things but
the full idea isn't really there and
there are cases where
people
have
there are some cases where people very
clearly wrote the the the full idea and
people ignored it
there are
that i think is a more sort of valid
case and they're cases where people sort
of got pieces of the idea but then it
wasn't really one didn't have the
conceptual framework to understand the
idea until a lot later i'll mention one
i mentioned ada lovelace this is
1840s um and she's writing this uh
uh
kind of commentary on babbage's
analytical engine
and she gives what i think when you read
it today is a pretty decently clear
description of kind of this abstract
notion of computation and even kind
kind of the idea of universal
computation but at the time
it has no
doesn't really get legs at all in fact
even when universal computation was
rediscovered
back
in the time of alan turing in 1936 and
so on and even even well even alan
turing's original paper wasn't that
notable when it first came out but
eventually kind of the the tide of
universal computation and all these
different methods that ended up being
equivalent became significant and
computers started being built and so on
after that kind of thing had happened
people went back and saw oh ada lovelace
had figured out a bunch of stuff and it
even said it quite clearly a lot earlier
but the world really wasn't ready for it
at that time i think you can go back
even further in that question of
universal computation look back at
gottfried leibniz and at his
characteristica universalis
um
his kind of idea of a kind of
a universal language for expressing
things and sort of read into that now
all sorts of ideas about computational
language and so on you know i i have
done the exercise where i've done it for
both fade and lovelace and for leibniz
of trying to look at their original
materials i would say in the case of
lovelace at least viewed from a modern
perspective the original materials are
quite clear viewed from a modern
perspective the leibniz materials as far
as i have looked at those ones in detail
are not clear at all
and you know it doesn't help well it
doesn't help they were in latin i can
more or less pick my way through that
but i haven't really tried to mostly do
it in the original form
but it's a thing where
that
is a
uh
you know it is presented
in something of its time
and that makes it harder much harder to
understand now so we're we're dealing
with a sort of multi-projection thing we
both we
we understand a bunch of concepts in our
way now are we as we look back at what
leibniz did in the late 1600s um how do
we sort of translate what we know now to
what he did then and then the other
problem of the way he represented things
in those days certain aspects of that
are kind of incomprehensible to us today
like a classic even from alan turing
you know you'll find in the writings of
alan turing something about how
you might do this and just work it out
on a brunsviga what is a bronze vega
well it's a it was a brand of mechanical
computer which existed in the time of
alan turing but for us today we'd have
to go hunt that down to find out what on
earth is that because it's not really a
thing
it's not a thing one one is heard of
today
so
you know i think this question of when
things get developed
they it is
the the sort of the easiest case to
understand is things are developed at a
time when the world is ready for them
the world sort of picks them up and
there's a continual thread of yes we
understand this was important and it
goes on being important and you can kind
of see oh yes this person originated it
nobody stole it from them whatever this
is um
this is the thing so to speak but there
are other cases where
there are things invented before their
time i think i might say that i
personally have probably done quite a
lot of that
um where the world isn't quite ready for
it and when the world kind of finally
says oh yeah we understand what that is
uh it's it's it's it's many years after
the original invention and the question
of whether people go back and really do
the history and figure out how that
worked is not is not clear
i think the other thing that can happen
is sort of the core phenomenon of
something is identified but nobody
really knew what it was i mean this
certainly has happened in
my own work
uh you know i mentioned this
multi-computation thing but even in the
core sort of discoveries of my new kind
of science book and the things around it
sort of discoveries about the
computational universe of simple
programs and the the very core discovery
that even very simple programs can
produce very complicated behavior that
has these features like computational
irreducibility and so on this idea that
even very simple rules can produce very
complicated behavior i have tried quite
hard to do the history of that and to
understand the precursors of that idea
and there are many
but
they weren't
that idea wasn't people didn't wrap
their arms around that idea so for
example people knew that prime numbers
had kind of a random distribution of
values
but people like gauss and riemann and so
on
they
just said well that's kind of a nuisance
what we really care about is the thing
that we can do some kind of mathematical
analysis on the regularity of the primes
not these random fluctuations that we
can't really understand
similarly digits of pi people knew that
the digits of pi were kind of random
like john ven inventor of venn diagrams
wrote this book in the 18
mid 1800s i think
in which he has a rather lovely picture
which may be the very first picture of a
random walk
and you know drawing a two-dimensional
random walk and how does he generate the
the uh
the directions for the random walk he
uses the digits of pi so he's very well
aware of the fact that the digits of pi
seem random but he doesn't make anything
of that he's just like well it's just a
thing the digits of pi random there's no
kind of implication for for example the
natural world when you look at the
natural world you see a lot of apparent
randomness in the natural world
why is there apparent randomness is it
like the digits of pi is it something
different people didn't internalize that
idea and it took basically a long side
road of understanding things from a
computational point of view and doing
actual computer experiments and so on of
things that i did um to to get back to
that idea even though
that idea was in a sense hiding in plain
sight
and um the uh
so those are those are some examples of
places where until you have the big
conceptual framework you don't get to
understand that there is really a thing
there another good example of this is
fractals
the i was curious when was the first
kind of example of a nested pattern
produced i think the answer is around uh
1208 a.d
done by a family of mosaic layers called
the cosmarte
um and you know i found the place in the
uh city called an agni
um
i don't know quite how it's pronounced
in um in italy where there is a you know
a crypt to the church and you can
actually see sort of because it's a
mosaic which has survived for these last
800 years you can kind of see
the uh the mosaic layers trying out
different kinds of things and eventually
they get it and they get this nested
pattern that nested pattern was sort of
invisible to people for hundreds of
years in the sense that yes it was a
nested pattern it kind of looked cool
but when art historians wrote about
these mosaic works
they would talk about the
representational art of lions and all
this kind of thing but when it came to
this nested pattern which was certainly
something you hadn't seen elsewhere just
ignored it didn't even mention it there
wasn't a conceptual framework available
for people to say oh yeah that's a
nested pattern and to describe it as a
matter of art history and things like
this
and in fact in the in the case of
fractals and so on the um
in the early 1900s people like [ __ ]
what's his first name helmut von koch
maybe um of the [ __ ] curve
and uh well people like cantor a little
bit less obviously geometrically were
creating these things that they were
doing largely as sort of counter
examples to continuity claims and
calculus of having these sort of
arbitrary arbitrarily rough surfaces and
so on but those weren't really a thing
they were just oh that's a random
example
the you know the hilbert curve space
filling curve piano space filling curve
these were just random pathological
examples there wasn't a a big theory a
big idea about
that that would cause people to say oh
yes these people discovered fractals so
to speak
and then when benoit mandelbrot came
along uh well in the 1970s primarily uh
that's kind of a funny story because
uh benoit
who i i knew reasonably well um i would
say uh although i'm not sure that we
necessarily uh well i i would say
um
uh let's say i was a fan of him but i'm
not sure he was a fan of me
um but uh
the um
uh he
had
uh
well he had kind of a curious history
because he had been uh you know he'd
grown up in originally poland then
france and um
he'd kind of gone through the french
sort of very mathematically
uh er
rigorous education
and he'd then gone off and really gone
into applied mathematics and
aerodynamics and all kinds of things
like that
rather than going in the french very
pure mathematics
kind of tradition although he'd been
sort of trained in that
and then he wound up
just doing a whole sequence of sort of
applied math kinds of things
eventually
getting very involved in studying power
laws and different kinds of things and
was interested in things like the zip
power law
for the frequency you know that the nth
most common word in english has
frequency roughly one over n
uh
the um
um a person called zip who was a long
time professor at harvard actually
in the 1930s and 40s had
wrote this book called the principle of
least effort which was a book that uh
purported to give sort of a general
quantitative theory of lots of kinds of
things in social science and lots of
sort of it was an early power lord
chaser um but anyway ben mandelbrot got
involved with that
and um
somehow
through that well we got involved in
language translation and then wound up
at ibm where he worked for many years
um but he it was sort of a a power laws
of fine power laws and things and he
wrote this book uh that was in french i
think uh sort of a precursor of his book
about a very famous book from the 1978
or so about fractals and then i think
his publisher his american publisher w h
freeman company um
were
like ah this book isn't that exciting
you know it's kind of like it's just a
bunch of power laws and so on can't you
spruce it up somehow
and that was what i think led to
uh particularly when we're uh tapping a
person called dick vos who was a
physicist at ibm
at the time and saying hey can you make
some pictures of all this stuff
and that was how this eventually very
richly illustrated book about fractals
came to be with all of these elaborate
pictures and upon seeing these once
you'd started doing this you know he
kind of just made these pictures of
everything and they were very very uh
engaging pictures and could connect this
kind of rather kind of typical applied
math we just got a you know a curve with
a bunch of numbers in it um kind of
thing to this very visual thing and that
really led to this kind of whole
idea of fractals and then one could go
back and see well all these things that
people had constructed in bermuda did
that of go back and see all these things
people had constructed in the early
1900s which were you know counter
examples and calculus now had a life
as part of this sort of paradigmatic
idea of fractals and so on so you know
it's complicated when things happen
relative to sort of the when the
conceptual framework gets developed and
so on
now you know there are other cases i
think uh the the the person who asked
this question originally mentioned
rosalind franklin i i don't know all of
the history of this i can tell you my
impression and this is what i get for
for trying to do all of these things
without ever looking anything up and
just doing everything from memory but my
impression is
rosalyn franklin was involved in the
whole 1953 dna
discoveries of of jim watson and francis
crick and so on but she was she'd worked
in london and she was an x-ray
crystallographer i believe um and the
first question was what is the shape of
you know what is the structure of dna
and you find that out by making doing
x-ray crystallography and i believe that
she did very
meticulous x-ray crystallography
crystallizing dna making x-ray
crystallographic images of it
but the problem with x-ray
crystallography is you're kind of like
getting a shadow of the structure of a
molecule and you're kind of getting this
well it's actually more like a fourier
transform of the structure of the
molecule and it's not unique you're kind
of projecting this the structure of the
molecule into this x-ray crystallography
image
and
that means that you know there are many
many possibilities what the molecule
actually might look like and it's sort
of a puzzle to figure out what does the
molecule actually look like given that
this is the x-ray crystallographic
result
my impression is she got the x-ray
crystallographic result and and watson
and crick did the thing with you know
making them a carno model and so on to
figure out well a double helix would be
the thing that would give that x-ray
crystallographic result and they
couldn't have done that without the work
that rosalind franklin did but the
question of where's the big you know
where was the big bang
you know in the end the big bang was
realizing again something which had been
suggested by other people i think george
gamoff may be a physicist who was also
involved in the big bang theory to to
just
bring that together um i think maybe
maybe he was later suggesting this i'm
not sure who exactly suggested the idea
that that there would be something
digital in dna but that was something
that watson and crick sort of brought
together with the extra crystallographic
results and then the realization that a
double helix that could
could kind of zip apart and zip together
again and so on could be the thing that
actually was the carrier of genetic
information so it's a complicated thing
you know what there are that you need a
particular thing that was a good piece
of science you needed that to be able to
make the next conclusion that ended up
being the conclusion that really had the
big big oomph to it
i think there are plenty of other cases
that one could start describing in the
history of science
where
it's complicated what people did and how
people recognized what they did one that
i studied a lot at the end of last year
was moses schoenfinkel who in december 7
1920
uh
announced these things called
combinators well combinators turn out to
be sort of the seed that has led us to
symbolic computation to uh and were sort
of the first
really formal concrete example of
universal computation they're also super
hard to understand even a hundred years
later it's really a brain twisting
exercise to understand combinators and
at the time sean finkel's work
largely vanished without trace they were
sort of discovered rediscovered by a
person called haskell curry who made a
whole career out of it
i i would claim that haskell curry
didn't really get the full significance
of sean finkel's work at least not for
many many years
and so that was a case where where sean
finkel had had just had created this
great thing but somehow and the paper
that he wrote about the thing is
actually very clear it's actually a very
well-written uh well-presented document
um but it was just a thing not in its
time and it was very hard for people to
understand it and and people didn't um
and and so that that kind of thing can
happen i suppose i'm also reminded of um
a person called stuckelberg who is as
sort of often uh
the person who has people talk about um
uh
inventor of many things around one field
theory and many kind of feminine diagram
like things and so on i i never met him
he was a although i could have done um
he was kind of a wild character from all
accounts uh coming from some um
uh kind of um
[Music]
i don't know what it counts as some some
sort of pseudo royal family type type
thing in europe uh maybe of some small
country and had a rather exotic kind of
um uh presentation of himself and also i
think had some uh sort of psychiatric
issues that took him out of action for
some part of his life but um uh the
baron baron von struckelberg right was
the the um um uh people will say that uh
you know he discovered this and that and
the other thing particularly around
quantum field theory i've not really
gone and investigated that to know um
and i think
uh you know
one of the things to to be clear about
the way that sort of science progresses
and people remember who who invented
this or that thing
there are a couple of things to say
first of all there's where does the big
conceptual framework come from where
does who really understood that and
understood that with clarity
and who explained it
those are some things
then when there are sort of point
discoveries like you discover a
particular thing
you know a particular axiom system for
this formal system whatever a particular
thing like that um those are things
which are point discoveries which
typically have a point discoverer so to
speak
sometimes there are things like like one
of the things that i'm always somewhat
amused by is that you know with our
mathematica system and so on endless
endless discoveries have been made with
it but
and probably those discoveries would not
have been made if it didn't exist
but yet it is basically just part of the
infrastructure and those discoveries
even though it may have been very easy
even though it may have taken only an
hour to do the computation necessary to
make some discovery given that you
already had mathematica it's in the kind
of the the value system of science it's
like well it's just the infrastructure
and the discovery is the important part
so it's kind of a complicated thing to
sort of know all of this and one of the
things that happens
in science is it is a it is an area
of
uh some good ethics and some very poor
ethics
um and you know it is
not at all uncommon that sort of
stealable discoveries will be stolen so
to speak um and certainly i've
experienced that a bunch of times in my
life
the um
where
it's one thing if it's a big conceptual
framework it's like it's it's way too
big a thing to sort of handle and and
maybe somebody will try and you know
i don't know rename it in their own uh
whatever but but it's generally
conceptual frameworks they take a long
time to build they take a long time to
absorb
it's different from sort of point
discoveries where it's like oh as soon
as you know the discovery you are off
having made the discovery and so that
that gets more sort of scurrilous i
would say in science with with some
rather depressingly high frequency
but in any case
all right let's see
many questions here
um there's probably more to say about
that but there's a question here from
parmenides
a more specific question about some
um
let's see about history of computer
algebra and so on asked did i meet uh
martinez veltman did i use his algebra
system sconeskip
uh way was i associated with any of the
other computer algebra systems like
reduce lamb sheep
cadabra and so on at cambridge
well let's see so yes i absolutely knew
tini veltman
um and i even wrote a post about him uh
when he died last year
uh was a person who um
had been
a physicist
who needed a tool
he needed a computational tool and he
built this
early computer algebra system
that had the sort of peculiar
distinction of being written in the
assembly language of a of a cdc series
computer
and having mnemonics that were in dutch
and so on so not exactly tops in terms
of user-friendliness but very good in
terms of of speed actually when i was
first building smp the forerunner to
mathematica and wolverine language
i went to visit teeny development in
utrecht this must have been 1979
probably
maybe 1978 i'm not sure around that time
and um sort of tried to get tips from
him for how to build a computer system
and uh he gave me some good tips and a
lot of pretty
in the end
let's say tips that didn't work anymore
like one of his tips was
floating point arithmetic is so much
faster on computers do everything with
floating point arithmetic
and back convert to rational numbers at
the end of the computation because you
can just zoom forward by using the
efficient floating point arithmetic of
computers that was true of the specific
scientific computers that he used that
they had fast floating point arithmetic
wasn't true of all computers and boy was
it a mess to represent as we did in snp
for a while at least rational numbers
small rational numbers as floating point
numbers and then go back and rationalize
them at the end that was a teen
development idea which i would say did
not work out terribly well i i might say
that in terms of those kinds of things
when you're dealing with uh results
about exact numbers like square root of
two plus square root of three plus
whatever
one of the things that's kind of funky
is one knows that in principle it's
possible to sort of decide whether some
combination of radicals etc etc etc is
equal to zero it's not an undecidable
question it's not something where there
could be an infinite length of proof
required to figure out whether this
whole combination of square roots and
cube roots and so on is equal to zero
but the actual procedure uh due to
alfred tarski for um uh for unraveling
those things um that's essentially
taski's decision procedure for for uh
equations over the over the reels and
complexes from the 1940s i guess
but his actual procedure is is
incredibly inefficient to implement but
one thing we've done over the last i
don't know 25 30 years
is
turns out you can just blast your way
through using floating point arithmetic
in much the way that teena development
suggested with rational numbers you can
blast your way through and get to the
answer so long as you can have theorems
that basically say
this number has to lie within this
interval in this particular place and so
on and that's kind of how we do those
kinds of uh of computations with great
efficiency so in a sense that's an
example of teen development's idea but
applied in a somewhat different domain
uh where it's a little bit less more
controlled than just saying every
rational number in the system is going
to be really floating point underneath
now um
uh did i use sconce skip and i'm not
pronouncing it very well because i don't
have a good dutch
pronunciation capability um i never used
it seriously i mean i i certainly
studied it
and played with it but i never used it
seriously
there were so
one collection of computer algebra
systems
was sort of initiated around 1962 by a
single meeting between three people at
cern that was tiny weltman
tony hearn
and mike levine and tony hearn
went on to develop
reduce
which was he had been sort of in the
stanford orbit in the john mccarthy was
the creator of lisp in that kind of
orbit and reduce was developed in lisp
um tony home was at university of utah
for a long time and then wound up i
think at the rand corporation in santa
monica
and uh
he um
that was and reduce was um was probably
the best distributed of these early
computer algebra systems
um and uh
i did use reduce um i used it actually
on a computer
in
well it was at the rutherford lab in
england
um
and i think um that must have been 1976
or so
uh and in any case that was um and tony
hearn i think subsequently had
involvement in the in the early openet
development and and other kinds of
things in the sort of computer area um i
believe he's still alive i exchanged
email with him within the last year or
two
um and uh
so he was the creator of reduce
now some of these other programs um that
you mentioned like sheep
um
i i don't know lamb i and i better do i
have a sheep
was a program for general relativity i
think it was done by a person called ray
dinverno if i'm not mistaken
who i think uh who i certainly met who
was in southampton at one point
um and i think
was uh
i guess that was developed in in
cambridge
um
and uh
it was
around the the camel program
c-a-m-a-l which somehow is a
one of its derivatives is the camel
now this is where i might be getting
confused because there was camel which
was a computer algebra system that was
particularly aimed at tensor
computations this was a system built in
the probably late 60s early 70s in
cambridge and camel and sheep were
somehow related
and
they were built for doing
mostly tensor manipulation general
relativity um
but there is also camel caml as opposed
to cm al which is also built in
cambridge and which
which then has become o camel which is a
kind of functional programming
kind of thing that's a little bit like
haskell
and i think the um
probably these are those two are both
derived from ml
which was a an early
uh kind of principled um sort of
denotational semantics based
uh
functional language
um which i don't think was ever
particularly practical and which then
sort of spun out
um haskell and i think the camel which
confusingly i think is not related to
the camel cam al
um although they were both originating
in the same place in cambridge
um those systems uh really didn't
intersect much with any of the general
purpose
uh computer algebra kinds of things i
think um
a
person named john fitch
who was at university of bath for a long
time
um
was involved with camel in cambridge and
i think subsequently was also involved
with reduce
um so maybe there's a connection there
but these are things where
the sort of the real thrust of those
systems was you've got these big kind of
you've got polynomials and things like
polynomials and things where essentially
the algebra is the bookkeeping you're
keeping track of all these tensor
indices and so on back in those days
things like the contraction of two
tensors you've got two riemann tensors
are on your new alpha beta or something
and another r whatever and you're
contracting these riemann tensors you
know using all the symmetries of the
indices the riemann tensors and so on
that's a lot of complicated bookkeeping
and back in the day there weren't very
streamlined algorithms known for that i
mean i i certainly imagined
from the late 1970s i was interested in
those kinds of questions and my
immediate sort of thought was this is
some graph theory problem you know
knitting together tensor indices like
that is sort of a problem of graph
theory and there's got to be a graph
theoretic way to sort of analyze that
that was a time when it wasn't yet as
well understood np completeness had been
sort of invented around 1970 it was sort
of emerging that there was this sort of
class of problems that were equivalent
difficulty and so on and many of those
were graph problems but that was
something not not well understood at
least not by me um and i think what
subsequently has come out is that it's
possible to use efficient graph
algorithms to kind of unscramble tensors
and things none of that was known to the
early computer algebra systems they were
really doing this kind of thing in a
very brute force kind of way now should
they have known um i think people like
roger penrose had started to invent kind
of graphical notations for tensors uh
back in the 1960s and early 70s but i
don't think there was a crossover
between that those inventions and the
kinds of things people were doing in
sort of the practical computer algebra
of general relativity that there could
have been but i don't think there was
um and in fact i really wasn't aware of
of the graphical notation for tensors um
it's only very recent times i really
come to care about this stuff um so you
know i i can't i can't uh make a
connection there
let's see
um
this question from primaries what
computer language was i using when i was
doing early particle physics research
um
so
uh the first language i used was a uh
assembler
called sir sir which was the assembler
for a machine called the elliott 903
and it was pretty painful to write stuff
in i then um uh used fortran a bunch as
probably fortran
wasn't yet fortran 77 because it was
earlier than 1977. it was fortran 66
which was very traditional fortran uh
used on mostly an ibm mainframe computer
and then a cdc 7600 this
computer as i recall
which was a sort of more scientifically
oriented compute large mainframe
computer
then i also used um
uh for some things i used a whole bunch
this is still
solidly 1970s um
i used well i used to use a hp
um
pen plotter kind of desktop calculator
computer type thing which was i guess
had some variant of basic um as its
language
and it had the nice feature that
actually had a built-in pen plotter and
you could make make graphs and things
with it um it was sort of the best way
to make graphs because in those days
what you got back from your sort of
running your card deck on a mainframe
was a printout from a line printer which
didn't have nice pictures in it the only
way you'd make pictures is with on
something like a tektronix storage scope
so there was this uh way of of writing
data that was i guess that was when
things got a little bit more interactive
you still had a um uh you're still using
vdus visual display unit um
uh
displays actually now that i think about
it i'm not completely certain that the
term vdu is an american computer term
because i used that term when i lived in
the uk um but uh
a cathode ray tube um display terminal
in which
all that it can display is characters it
just had an electron beam that had a a a
um a kind of a a metal plate that had
the shapes of characters and depending
on where the electron beam was deflected
it would paint one character or another
character onto the phosphor on the on
the actual display screen and so that
was the primary way that you interacted
with computers was through a tele-type
you know textual terminal when you
wanted a graphical display there was
sort of a different technology of these
tectronic storage scopes
uh
that they had sort of started life as
oscilloscopes
but they were storage in the sense that
you would uh you get this picture and
back in the day they were probably um uh
storing things through just sort of
recycling the um uh you know the data
through a cathode ray tube effectively
as an analog thing but by the time this
was probably 1977
or so 1970 1977-ish
um what would happen
is that you could get this display
on this
storage scope
and you could press a button and there
would be some thermal printer that would
print essentially a photographic image
of that that display i mean if you look
at papers from the 1950s where people
were trying to get kind of computer
displays rendered like i think fermi
pasta unulam in the mid-1950s at los
alamos when they were studying
non-linear springs and and nonlinear
oscillators and so on and eventually
discovering solitons and so on um i
think the pictures they made were
literally photographs from an
oscilloscope um they're just photographs
of you know driving an oscilloscope with
a computer and getting the result i mean
i would say that the top technology for
making a plot
back in the 1970s was you take a piece
of graph paper you take a pencil you
read off the numbers you plot them on
the graph you join the points together
that was the that was the number one
technology so it was a big luxury to use
you know an hp pen plotter or this
tektronix storage scope or whatever else
um
then
well what i used uh so i used reduce
back in 1976 i used ashmedi
1977. i used maxima starting in 1976.
um i used a bunch of different kinds of
systems but i was primarily using
um
uh as a as a kind of base programming
language i was primarily using fortran
1978
i
started using c
there was a young
then physics graduate student named rob
pike
at caltech
who was like c is the language of the
future
he said um and
the
in
and at the time c had been used
uh in the development of the unix
operating system and it kind of was a
sort of a little bit of systems
programming language and so on it had
been developed so used a lot on the
pdp-11 i i never used a pdp-11 i used
the vax 11780 which was the kind of
bigger grown-up version of the of the
p2p 11.
um the
but um i sort of got introduced to see
now of course
uh rob pike went on and wrote several
books about unix and so on and then of
course having explained to me back in
those days that c was the language of
the future rob developed his own
language go um uh
in i don't know what it was 10 years ago
now which has been a a quite successful
systems implementation language i think
rob is always
something of a minimalist
and um he
liked the minimalism of c and i think he
sort of carried that minimalism through
to go
um and uh uh that that's some it's sort
of a that's a that's a micro footnote to
history but then i started using c
um and that was the implementation
language for my smp system and it was
also the core implementation language
for the mathematical morphing language
although we built kind of an extension
to that that was sort of an
object-oriented extension to see
um that uh we did because c plus plus
had been invented but there were not
native c plus compilers by 1987
and um
so it was very inefficient to use
something like c plus plus uh and so we
built our own kind of minimalized memory
management oriented version of c um that
uh we still use um in in some parts of
the core kernel of our system
so there's a question here
what's my perspective on thoranus did i
have awareness of skepticism the company
before it collapsed
you know it's funny because there are
places where
you're kind of if you're in the tech
industry or whatever else
there are things where you kind of
there's a sort of osmosis of information
about certain kinds of things and oh
you've always met the person who did it
because there are enough conferences and
people get together and so on and so on
so on you kind of know people who know
people and it's kind of thoroughness was
a little odd for me because because i
really didn't know those people at all
and i i i had to specifically ask people
i knew
who were in that sort of space do you
know these people oh yeah i met them
once type thing it was not a very
connected uh it was not as connected as
these things often are
i think that um my impression
is that um
uh
you know i have no idea
what um
the details of all the things that
happened or didn't happen or whatever
and how much the
how much sort of
it's a reality distortion field
that is just what you need to sell
investors versus it's a reality
distortion field that's just outright
sort of malicious
stuff i i have no idea i have no no
impression of that
i was um uh i had certainly heard i mean
the the rumor was
that
sort of the big idea of thiranos
was a different way of doing sort of
calibration and error analysis
for measurements that is there's sort of
a question of you you know you get some
measurement and you're you're sort of
doing some electrochemistry to get some
results and how do you know you know
what's the error what does the error
distribution look like that was my was
what i had sort of heard was the the
secret source so to speak now i have to
say
i was um
uh this must have been oh gosh years ago
five years more than that
um uh theranos had announced that they
were putting some sort of clinics into
um
uh
uh into actual retail type stores and i
happen to be walking down the main
highest what's it called the main street
in palo alto what is it called
uh high street or something in palo alto
actually with a person
named linda avey who is one of the
founders of 23andme
um and uh uh
there was a a sign that literally said
you know theranos tests available here
and it was some
was it wolven some other i forget one of
the um uh one of the the sort of
pharmacy chains and so i was like let's
go in here let's see what's happening
and so we go in there and it's like
there's some poor tech
um kind of in the back of the store and
we're like okay
you know probably me because i'm more
forward about these kinds of things okay
can i get you know
a a a finger prick and get my my data
read and what kinds of data can you read
and so on and so on and so on and this
tech was very confused and unimpressive
and when we sort of asked questions
about well you know what
what kind of a thing are you going to
measure what's the accuracy what tests
are available etc etc etc the story was
very amorphous
which certainly didn't encourage me i
mean you know sometimes it can be the
case that you can have a company that is
completely wonderful but by the time its
products get out to sort of retail
distribution the people who are dealing
with its retail distribution can be uh
you know can have little knowledge of of
what the core wonderfulness was but so
so it's hard for me to have a clear
impression i mean i would say that in
in the world of um
uh
you know in in
in
sort of this question of of due
diligence on companies and people come
to me all the time with
kinds of
uh sort of companies and and ideas and
things in from physics and so on that
have
a
you know where people say we've got this
miraculous thing
that um
uh
uh you know works in some miraculous way
and i have to say i have dug my way
through quite a number of those in my
life
and often one gets it right sometimes
one doesn't get it right um i have to
say i
uh i can i could describe some of the
cases where people sort of said they had
some magic thing and i was like well i i
don't quite see it and turned out they
did um i think i rarely got it wrong the
other way around i would tell one story
um which i suppose i can tell this is
from um
when was it probably 1980 perhaps
i had
i knew this person
who
was
kind of a physicist who had some
investment money and so on connected to
him and there was another physicist
who
was i think a particle physicist at cern
who was like i've invented a
zero flux transformer
and uh this investmenty oriented
physicist was asking what do you think
of this you know is this a this is a
real thing is this something that one
should pay attention to
and i'm like my heuristic would be no
the person who's invented it is some
particle physicist who works on field
theory this is a transformer which is a
piece of electrical engineering and why
you know
there's
it's not clear you know i could just
imagine you know physicists are are
famous for just
saying you know let's come into some
field and uh let's say you know ignore
everything that's been done in this
field let's do it afresh
now that's a double-edged sword because
sometimes they're right sometimes the
physicists can come into a field and say
hey guys the stuff you've done before
doesn't make a lot of sense we can just
redo it all and they do something
amazing and sometimes they come into the
field and it's like actually they're
just ignoring all the stuff that's been
done and they're just getting it
completely wrong so my heuristic was
yeah i kind of think that's more likely
than not what's going on in this case
okay so many many many years go by and i
didn't you know i remember this the
situation that didn't really pay
attention and then i realized many years
later that the person the physicist who
had um
done this had indeed gone and started a
company and that company had become
quite large and that company was
basically making
most of the power supplies most of the
transformers for laptops and things like
this and with the kind of it used to be
the case you have to get a different
transformer if you wanted to run with
110 volts versus 240 volts um this
person's invention basically got rid of
all of that uh issue um to uh uh to make
it uh go across those different voltages
and sort of became a large company so
this was a case where it was kind of
like does this magic thing work
well that was the much younger me was
like hey i don't think so and yet it did
and so it's hard to tell you really have
to dig in and see
and you know i think that there can be
situations in which people
uh you know i've been surprised you know
when i get presented with different
kinds of companies and this and that and
the other and you know will i be
involved or help out in some particular
thing you know i tend to try and do
reasonable due diligence
of what's really underneath this
and i have to say i have been very
surprised in some cases that people who
i think are pretty prominent and etc
have gotten involved with things where
when you look underneath it's like oh my
gosh this is completely crazy
and and that yet you know if you just
said well who's involved it would look
like oh there's a great collection of
people involved and you figure somebody
must have done the due diligence on this
and turns out maybe nobody did
and and so i don't you know i don't know
how that all played out and in this
particular case
and i i feel like there's you know i
have to say when i first saw these kind
of attack
you know journalism
against theranos i i i was like why are
these people attacking like this this
seemed like a very un
un kind of savory un
uh you know dramatic attack and i didn't
quite get the whole the whole story of
what was going on um and so it's hard
for me to parse
what um uh what actually happened no
doubt uh well maybe maybe not i don't
know whether the um uh
whether you know in the in the grim
uh sort of details of of legal testimony
whether one whether the story will
actually become clearer or not i don't
know i mean i think it's always one of
these things where
um
it is certainly the case
that there are companies um
where
i mean i can think of several examples
where
when you first see the company it's like
guys your technology is just this
technology is awful
and you know it's you're just not gonna
it's not gonna get there
and then they raised a bunch of money
and then they backfill that technology
with something quite real after the
concept has been created by technology
that's kind of crummy and and held
together with you know ceiling wax or
whatever and then you know when it's
back filled what what it what is
produced
when it is backfilled is really good of
course there are other cases where the
technology is kind of cruddy at the
beginning and people say it's great it's
great it's great and they they promote
it and they're like look it's an amazing
thing
and and it's just all nonsense and it
just there was nothing there so it's
it's a you know it's complicated and i
would say that the the the social
dynamics
uh the one thing that i would say i
would i would sort of call out of that
social dynamics is my surprise
that
uh people don't do
people do surprisingly poor due
diligence and i you know sometimes it's
really hard to do sensible due diligence
i mean i i
not to name names but but you know
there's a there's companies i've been
sort of peripherally involved with where
it's like a device
and it's like does the device work
and like does it do what it says it's
going to do
and you can like well send me a device
oh we can't send you a device because
they require hookup to this and that and
the other and it's you know story story
story
um and you don't get the device
and um the
and then it's like but look all these
amazing customers are using the device
does the device work i would like to
with my own hands you know
try the device because then i'll know if
it works or doesn't work oh but why do
you want to try the device look we just
made all these deals with all these
people who are buying devices from us
okay you know that's the question of to
what extent do you trust your own
judgment about these things and to what
extent do you go with kind of well other
people think it's good so it must be
good
and as i say my my experience has tended
to be that this other thing people think
it must be good so it must be good is uh
has been surprisingly poor i think the
the one that's in sort of in my
crosshairs right now is quantum
computing and just what works and what
doesn't because i've had kind of a
five-year tale of people telling me oh
yeah you can run this computation on our
quantum computer
i've never once yet actually done it
it's always been oh but well well it's
better to do it on the simulator oh our
machine is down today
all these kinds of things so i have to
say that if i were to pick a kind of a
crosshairs right now
uh and i've also worked a lot on the
theory of these things so i have
opinions from that although the
connection between the theory and the
practice is not a hundred percent uh at
least in my mind but um that's a case
where i i think um um
the uh
um
that's um uh that's that all right
well anyway um
oh boy
i'm just i'm i'm i'm
you ask such interesting questions guys
so i'm i'm i'm i know i have another
meeting which actually is being live
streamed but i'll i'll try and do just a
couple more here
um
the
ah yeah
um
well maybe i'll just do one more from
oscar here i'll leave some others for
another time
um
oscar asked what are tensors and where
did they originate from
he says i use them for machine learning
but don't even know what they are
okay
so
tensors
originated in the study of stress
stress in materials solid mechanics
and what are they how did they originate
and that's why tensors it's all about
tension
and it's all about sort of deformation
of a solid object and so on
so
in terms of
what a tensor is
well
back people didn't really much have the
idea of vectors
until
what the mid-1800s at least and the idea
that you could package together the x
component the y component the z
component
the um by the time
of so things like vector analysis
were really developed for purposes of
electrodynamics and fluid mechanics
and this idea of sort of packaging
things together as the velocity is a
vector with three components
um but we can just call it v
that was the thing that people like
james kirk maxwell when he wrote his
textbook of electrodynamics
in the 1890s maybe 1880s
he definitely had that idea by that time
now that was vectors
uh
there were
confusingly enough sort of a competing
technology was hamilton's quaternions
because if you want to represent a
direction in three dimensional space one
way you can do it is by giving the x y z
coordinates uh another way you can do it
is by using quaternions where you have
not a complex number not a number with
an a a a real part an imaginary part but
in addition to a one and an i you also
have a j and a k
and the algebra of plutonians was
developed by um
uh william roland hamilton
who famously when he invented them you
know was like i just had this great idea
and uh when he was out walking or
something and he carved them on the side
of some bridge somewhere in ireland
where i think they are still to be seen
um but it's like i usually carry a
little piece of paper in my pocket and
of course by now i have a you know a
smartphone and all those kinds of things
so the idea that one came up with on
one's walk uh for me it would just be on
my little piece of paper or something or
i might send myself email or something
like that but for willow hamilton his
best way was carve them on the side of a
bridge with a stick or something i
suppose
but um in any case quaternions were sort
of a competing technology for vectors
which didn't really win out um uh
they're still used they're actually
perhaps in some ways increasingly used
for representing 3d rotations for
purposes of of computer graphics and
things like that but for many purposes
vectors are a much cleaner idea because
a vector is in general not just in three
dimensions it's just a list
of
things
for example a list of numbers in any
other dimensions that's a vector
so then what about matrices so matrices
today seem like a very obvious idea a
matrix is a list of lists let's say or a
matrix is something where there are
numbers and every number has an i j
has a has an x coordinate and y
coordinate in this in this grid matrices
are an obvious idea but they weren't an
obvious idea historically they were i
think invented by arthur cayley in the
1870s maybe
um arthur cayley was a mathematician who
was deeply involved in things like group
theory and so on and he invented
matrices i think
as part of the theory of invariance
and all these things about polynomials
and when polynomials are uh invariant
under transformations and a whole and
the theory of determinants was part of
this because to make a determinant
there's an easy way to sort of package
that as matrix so matrices were a
comparatively
comparably recent invention and they
were not invented structurally they were
invented for their purpose of use in
studying things about transformations of
polynomials and so on
the the structural use of matrices of
just there's an array of numbers and you
know you can take them as a packaged
array of numbers and do things with them
that was a thing that emerged i don't
think that really had emerged
strongly
until
probably until the 1960s until people
were first starting to do linear algebra
on computers
i think there were certainly efforts i
mean people were studying i don't know
stan
was at one point studying infinite
matrices
um
and uh that must have been in the 1930s
and 40s something like that
uh so that was a it was a thing but it
was a much more theoretical thing it
wasn't something where it's like there's
this thing it's an array of numbers uh
you know you can use it as a packaged
array of numbers and and move it around
now tensors i think originated
in uh the study of stress and strain so
uh people you know michael faraday had
invented this idea of fields the idea
that there could be a uh for example for
electromagnetic field that there could
be an electric
uh field vector at every point in space
that was kind of a faraday construction
later sort of mathematicized by people
like uh maxwell
but this idea of a field um
was then sort of something in in well
the navier-stokes equation of fluid
dynamics they date from the
1830s maybe
and that was i don't know how they were
originally formulated they were probably
not as cleanly written in terms of
vector analysis and and vectors and so
on as they are today
but sometime around then the equations
of stress and strain were being
developed and the point is that in a in
a fluid the thing that matters is the
velocity
and um the um
uh
it's some
uh the question is so velocity is just a
vector it tells you the fluid is flowing
around this way
okay when you have a solid object it's a
bit more complicated because you can
have a distortion in a solid object
you're kind of twisting a piece of the
solid object and or you're you're
putting a force in the solid object and
there's a question of the force in what
direction
through what
surface in the solid object because if
you're kind of shearing a solid object
it's like you're putting a force
in that there's a force vector here but
there's a where is that force acting
well it's acting across this plane that
is sort of shearing in the solid and so
that led to the introduction of tensors
that were
representing this kind of tension in a
solid and that was beyond a vector it
was something that had to have more
directions in it so to speak that a
vector has in it so subsequently of
course tensors have a very structural
character which is just involved in
language for example we make it very
clear a tensor is a list of lists of
lists that's a rank three tensor you can
have in general rank n tensor which is a
list of lists of lists of this whatever
recursively end times that's our modern
view of a tensor is just a packaging of
uh this sort of uh rectilinear packaging
of numbers
and it is interesting that
the the kind of the the whole idea of
sort of vectors tensors and things like
that for example in computer languages
apl developed by ken iverson in the
1960s was sort of a language that took
the idea of vectors and tensors very
seriously and took the idea that there's
a a single thing a single variable it
can be a vector variable a tensor
variable etc um that was a place where
that got taken very seriously and that
was sort of i think the origination of
many of the kind of uses of vectors i
certainly use the ideas from apl in
developing things in waltham language um
to do with the the way that we handle
things like vectors and tensors and so
on actually about to have another level
of innovation in that kind of thing
which is sort of symbolic ideas meets uh
sort of actual structure of those kinds
of um uh those kinds of things but but
anyway so tensors they're all about
tension and solids and um it was only
subsequently that they were sort of
understood as a as a structural
packaging that could be used i mean when
tensors were introduced the other big
use case for tensors with general
relativity and the uh and the
representation of the structure of space
of the um of um
of curvature in space-time uh the
riemann tensor needless to say is named
after bernard riemann um and he invented
that
in the study of in the general study of
surfaces and so on in the mid-1800s but
that was then
i don't think anything that exciting
happened with it at that time it was
really well people like gauss had also
worked on things like that riemann i
think had sort of generalized it and um
and so on um that stuff and the work by
ritchie also
got um uh got really picked up and used
in um uh
by einstein
in 1915 when he developed general
relativity
and i think his friend um
michelle bezo
was the um was one of the people who
sort of introduced him to this whole
uh sort of idea of tensors and so on um
and obviously uh einstein and david
hilbert were kind of racing for the the
theory um and i guess david hilbert
probably knew about tenses who was
mathematician probably separately knew
about tensors i don't know that for sure
but einstein was always fond of saying
that um uh you know the mathematics that
he had to do was at the very limit of
what he could possibly manage because
he'd been sort of trained in mathematics
through physics and of course tensors
hadn't been a thing in physics and he
really had to import this mathematics
into into physics and i kind of feel
that way myself in some of the things
we're doing in our physics project now
of importing things from higher category
theory and so on which are things which
are sort of at the limit of my
mathematical uh uh sort of uh reach
and um uh but they're things which i
think can be fruitfully imported into
into physics now and i feel a kind of a
i i i definitely
feel what um uh you know i i know what
old albert was feeling when he was
talking about you know look i've got
these tenses they're these wonderful
shiny objects in mathematics and you
know can i pull them into can i
understand them enough to pull them into
what i'm doing in physics
all right i think i have to run off here
um
and uh
i am thanks very much lots of
interesting questions we've got a lot of
good ones uh left
for the next um episode um which should
be in a couple weeks
so thanks for joining me